solène bonjour alors vous êtes à lille
avec des gels et jaune autour de vous
comment se présente cette journée eh
bien écoutez pour ce nouvel acte comme
vous le disiez les gilets jaunes se sont
donné donc tous rendez vous à lille un
appel a été lancé sur les réseaux
sociaux et plusieurs centaines de gilets
jaunes ont répondu à cet appel
beaucoup de gens sont déjà en train
d'affluer place de la république pour un
départ tout à l'heure à 14h30 il s'agit
d'une manifestation autorisée par la
préfecture de lille a déclaré bien
évidemment une manifestation en marge
des déclarations d' emmanuel macron donc
vous parliez tout à l'heure le chef de
l'état qui s'est dit ouvert au dialogue
et prêts à recevoir les gilet jaune pour
l'instant aucune déclaration de leur
côté concernant ses déclarations d'
emmanuel macron merci beaucoup
cela ne gobe d'un pour toutes ces
précisions en direct de lille merci